three of the weirdest races in three
locations across America starting out
dune buggies second we're on the water
and swamp boats in Florida
and finally dogsled racing in Alaska
we'll be keeping track of the scores
throughout all the races in the end
there's gonna be one winner and one
shitty shitty loser last time it was a
gene that was hilarious
[Music]
it's the try guys dirty tour
[Music]
[Music]
last season the guys from the Grand Tour
had us fight each other in a demolition
derby racing last season we drove dune
buggies in Namibia and we'd like to
challenge you to try guys to race each
other in the desert thanks for letting
us know you got to go to Namibia that's
[ __ ] cool yeah and since we've done
dune buggies we'd like you to be a bit
creative and do it in some other kind of
vehicle
I hear you James I don't love sand I
like sand
I don't know everyone's like I don't
like sad why are we driving on sand you
race in a race track and that's where
I'm good I think I'm an amazing driver
my wife thinks I'm too cautious this
dirty tour is just a way for us to get
one with nature and I'm very excited
about it I got the Mad Dog demolition
derby y'all know who real Mad Dog yes hi
my name is zak I work at Sun buggy we
rent out dune buggies and ATVs and the
Oceano Dunes so state vehicular
recreation area it's truly like another
planet the terrain is very unpredictable
cliffside ranges in height from like I
don't know two feet you know almost a
hundred hundred foot drops
[Applause]
do you know how people started doing
this you know there's a freedom to it
what's the worst injury you've ever seen
Danny picks oh yeah order so you guys
want to see it looks like Korean
barbecue what are we doing what kind of
safety gear will we have for this you
have four point harness is you know
shoulder harnesses and waist belt
there's one on the other side rusty I
think it would help me feel more secure
okay buckle me and maybe you have to
sing me a lullaby where does this thing
go though then this goes this way and
then I do that and then we did it you
guys got it yeah
it's getting a little confusing like
hearing them call you Zach because my
name's Zach can we come up with like a
different name for you I'm pretty sure
I'm older than you what's your middle
name
andrew is now my quest in life to crush
all of you don't worry about it saying
the ending is getting these bugs I'm not
gonna lie I'm feel pretty unsafe right
now so you'll see just these marauding
hordes of people on self-built vehicles
and dirt bikes and stuff like that Matty
let's go you can be a marauding horde we
can finally become a marauding horde
anything goes in the Doudna oh god
there's so many birds sitting at the
beautiful show
there's many birds it's the entire dune
complex is about 18,000 acres and even
though the writing area that off highway
version of it is not that big it still
visually goes for miles and miles a
difficult place to get to on foot and it
is gorgeous
families come out here and they get
close to 2 million visitors a year in
this park the biggest challenge people
have with the buggies is getting stuck
and I know none of you guys are gonna
get stuck oh my god keep it stuck oh
crap he's stuck I don't intend on
getting a horse on are you stuck - yeah
I'm stuck
don't hurt yourself um why why do people
race on sand oh it's really fun the idea
is for you to go out have a good time
and to be able to explore an area that
otherwise you wouldn't believe it
alright so should we jump in the cars
and start ripping these dudes
we're gonna set up a short skills course
for you to make sure you have the three
basic skills gonna be required to make
it through your race tomorrow first
skill is gonna be a banked turn the
second skill is gonna be a hill climb
the third skill is gonna be a hill
descent
go for it I might be a dad soon so I
just don't want to get hurt today best
thing you can do for yourself is to give
up as soon as it's not doing what you
wanted to do
the quicker you give up the easier the
recovery is them
righto baby
it worked
like I think you have to go to the
rescue
hey Eugene one real quick that's nice I
like that lift it up higher yes oh my
god so I take my pants off too or what
[Music]
I'm obviously the front runner for today
I'll sorry I'm just playoff beard the
other guys keep saying keep these are
playoffs I'd say eat my dust losers nice
beard
oh man I think it's good
[Music]
I am the best driver the try guys it's a
family Rico come on come on sandy Andy
it's really really fun it honestly feels
like a roller coaster
not used to being good at things that
was amazing
all right bye guys
okay always low why is he gonna sit
though no yeah most of my practice was
spent leisurely strolling around taking
nice little ganders at all the hills the
horizon
[Music]
timid turn down your gene turn down
there it is he's right where I was maybe
just sandy Amy and Keith are good at
this guy gonna high-five you know if you
give up right away you can just roll the
buggy backwards and drive away all of
these vehicles and modes of transport
have been designed to work harmoniously
within the space that they're riding
within I was the most efficient in
getting my car out of being stuck
it really feels like we're on the
surface of the sand planet I just feel
so good I've never had so much
positivity going into anything I've
become most spiritually connected with
the terrain will that come in handy not
if I don't drive fast we're here we're
in the dunes we're ready
it's stay over - and I'm crushing this
this is dune world and anything that
[ __ ] happen I'm just so good at this
I like when Keith and Zac gain
confidence because it usually doesn't
pay off sandy Andy gotta name is that a
weird playground kid that nobody wants
to hang out with not worried about ya
know I'm like crushing this they keep
calling me sandy Andy and I feel like
the jealous me if all things are equal I
am the best I have a fear ranking in my
head me full-frontal Fullmer coming at
you it's a doom loss baby I also like
when Ned loses confidence because he
usually ends up raging I do think Ned is
gonna attack today with a vengeance I
hope that that backfires the past year
I've been probably the most relaxed try
guy when it comes to competitions I
think I need to maybe tap back into that
primal Eugene spirit the one that wants
to go at your throats you can't ever
really totally count Eugene out it does
have met you guys realize that right
he's a wizard
all right so excited we're gonna put the
skills you learned yesterday to the test
we set up a pretty challenging course
for you look in the distance you'll see
two hills of vegetation on them
go around the hill on the right around
the hill on the left and circle the hill
on the left one time
and then make your way back here you'll
see some gates with some checkered flags
the goal is to get through the gate run
over and pick your weapon of choice for
sliding down the hill you need to cross
the finish line with your device and
like I said yesterday give up if it's
not doing what you think you should do
stop the path to victory is given up
maybe that's why me and Sandy are doing
so well all right boys whatever happens
we're still try guys your life right
yeah supposed to shake hands this is how
we've never done this well let's do the
race what is it yes as a balaclava made
out of paper
it's a baklava oh my god I think if you
don't where you're gonna look pretty
stupid Eugene do I look like a ninja and
white I look like a medieval sperm
I feel pretty prepared this is actually
the first time I've ever done a car race
alright see gene you are the most one
with the sand this is your element you
can be your dirty friends I think that
going straight is actually not the right
move I think that there's a surprise so
I'm aiming right you're stealthy they
won't see you coming sandy full foul
Fulmer just gotta open that frontal baby
all right boys let's see what you got
let's get this dirty tour started on
your mark
dad said
No
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god this is crazy
I'm betting on this being the better way
to go we're going on a cliff we're going
on a cliff oh my god this is nuts
cliff
yes okay my tragedy is working out right
now he's out in front he gave me
take a far-right room
kinda
[Music]
work out exactly as I hope a bride a
mother behind you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm really in fourth place right
now
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm down ba-baby full-throttle gotta
catch up to you Sam Sam sand in my face
yeah come back I am sandy and all over
the place
you geez get off of my laptop I'm coming
for you keep them to murder you I'm
gonna take your head and spit it on my
wall it's the finish line I can see it
it's gonna be a sprint to the finish cap
here you go
[Music]
Oh
hello
[Music]
all right which one sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tonight we'd already don't give up
[Music]
I do this I was the guy that was losing
the entire way and then had some
[ __ ] at the end to win this isn't
how supposed to happen I'm the underdog
I grab the duck big mistake idiots
didn't grab the best sled might have
thought that this spell I cast was just
for this race but no there's two more
locations for people to have some
unfortunate accidents the worst part is
that I really really enjoyed this and
then I just [ __ ] up so hard sandy Andy
sandy Andy
sandy Andy
witchcraft
downtown scoop it out the duck [ __ ] me
over that's why I autocorrect always
changes [ __ ] - duck same [ __ ] thing